okay for those of you who remember I
actually enjoyed the first pitch perfect
movie so let's review the single pitch
perfect 2 2 pitch perfect 2 sequel to
pitch perfect no [ __ ] and this movie
starts out feeling like it's just more
of the same that we saw from the first
pitch perfect movie they're having a
performance and there's something really
embarrassing happens so they're kind of
blackballed from acapella but they were
like hey if we win nationals can we
still do acapella so they're given the
green light so now they have to get back
into it so all those movies that feels
like the sequels the byproduct of the
success which happens a lot and usually
it's kind of camouflaged into there if
it's masterfully made hopefully you can
hide the fact that it's just made to
make money I guess it it's a business
but it's just a parent in this movie but
there are things that I really enjoyed
about this movie first of all the
acapella I like acapella I like music I
like tapping my foot I like a good beat
this movie has that and I was enjoying
it and I was into it and it Kendrick is
great in this movie rebel Wilson she
does more of the same stuff but she's
really good at doing the same stuff so
until she becomes melissa mccarthy and i
get sick of it I'm gonna enjoy rebel
Wilson but all-in-all the movie gets
really sloppy first of all they've lost
their mojo they've lost their synergy
and their ability to work together when
they've apparently won the championships
for the last three years in between
these movies now they got to get their
mojo back so they go to boot camp it's
just a way to shoehorn characters from
the first movie into the second movie
and all of this is happening and is
taken away from the interesting things
that were happening in the movie before
seriously you're watching you're like
can we go back to Anna Kendrick's job
and the Kendrick in this movie she has
an internship because she's kind of
looking to okay I want to do things in
the world school's not gonna last
forever
which is actually a good arc to do in a
college movie it's like what do we do
after college so she's at this recording
studio and her boss abilities key from
key & peele Obama's anger translator
that dude yeah he's in this movie the
guy is funny this is the funniest I have
ever ever seen him dude was hysterical
every scene he was in he was completely
crushing this scene but it's a small
part in the movie says a little
internship thing that kind of happens
then when she's not there I'm like can
you go back cuz it's the best part of
the movie skip out on your acapella made
sure if it means we can go back and see
more of that dudes monologues and to be
honest I wanted this national
championship to be this big thing and
there were a couple of good segments and
they had you know the fields but it
wasn't like b-rabbit verse
Papa Doc if he and debate mile or
anything like that it wasn't like this
five stage boss flight where you're like
oh yeah we're here for like fifteen
solid minutes I guess I'd get a little
taxing and exhausting but I just wanted
to see more it happened you enjoy it for
what it was in the movie and a lot of
jokes in this movie they just beat over
your head they overuse the joke the
Mexican girl makes Mexican jokes a
little Asian girl we know she's weird
she's kind of crazy maybe every scene
there's Asian girls and she has to do
something weird and creepy there were a
few characters in this movie that had
that it's just like dude I get the joke
I really do can you stop and get back to
the acapella or at least have Anna
Kendrick go back to her internship so we
can watch that and laugh I simply put
pitch-perfect to had a lot of what was
in the first movie to a point where
they're just recycling a lot of stuff in
the first movie I won't deny it the
music was catchy the best part of the
acapella was actually about halfway
through the movie there's like this
little battle thing they do like a
five-on-five really cool stuff in fact
it was better than the acapella that was
at the end of the movie things I enjoyed
things I didn't not as good as the first
one I will say if you really loved the
first pitch-perfect maybe like I have a
cousin she loves the first one she is
going to love this one you enjoy that
movie teenage girls you but for me pitch
perfect to would be a better time if I
were drunk ya know it's a party trailer
to Jim still suck stuff price of [ __ ]
perfect - have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
wanna see more click right here to see
more